[Music]
kate middleton makes casual
look super chic during a trip to the
natural history museum
in london the duchess of cambridge
donned a dusty rose jacket
a white top jeans and sneakers for the
outing
which was just a short drive from her
london home kensington palace
where kate promoted the museum's urban
nature project which aims to help people
reconnect with the natural world
and understand the importance of nature
in towns and cities
the 39 year old royal sat cross-legged
in the museum's garden
and joined some kids as they learned
about spiders and as she left the museum
kate attached an acoustic monitoring
device to a cherry tree in the wildlife
garden
which will record ambient sound to help
scientists investigate patterns of bird
mammal and insect activity in the garden
of course it's been a busy time for the
cambridges on sunday williams celebrated
father's day by helping kick off a half
marathon in norfolk england
the couple's two eldest kids
seven-year-old prince george and
six-year-old princess charlotte attended
the event with their dad
and were right by his side to count down
to the start of the race
on monday the duke of cambridge turned
39 years old
and his dad prince charles marked the
occasion with this sweet throwback pick
holding william as a baby
he captioned the instapost quote wishing
the duke of cambridge a
very happy birthday today the royal
family account which represents
william's grandmother queen elizabeth ii
also shared a sweet family photo of
william and kate with their three
children on the account's insta story
and speaking of children the royal
family keeps growing
earlier this month kate told reporters
that she can't wait to meet her newborn
niece
i can't wait to meet her because we
haven't yet
yet met her yet so hopefully that will
be soon
of course meghan markle and prince harry
welcomed their second child
lillabet on june 4th following the birth
of the sussex's daughter
the royal family took to social media to
congratulate the couple
and a source previously told et that
while they made a coordinated public
effort to congratulate and offer harry
and megan well wishes
there are still lingering feelings of
disappointment and anger
after the couple's claims in their
explosive oprah interview
where they accused and unnamed member of
the royal family
of expressing concern about the
potential color of their son archie's
skin
before he was born i think everyone's
hope is that this
little baby is going to be a rift healer
because this family division has really
gone on for
a very long time now it's well over a
year we know that there have been some
really quite deep problems between harry
and william
difficulties between harry and his
father and i think it's everyone's
hopes that this little baby will will be
a peace offering
in many ways and that she will help to
bring this divided family
back together
you